at the test track in miramar southern
france BMW recently presented the latest
products of its research into
alternative drive technologies here are
three systems currently under
development number one hydrogen fuel
cell technology integrated here into a
demo vehicle based on the BMW 5 Series
Gran Turismo the hydrogen fuel cell is
among the frontrunners to replace or
complement internal combustion it
combines zero emissions with driving
comfort dynamics and long range
capability potential of Gong strobel of
the hydrogen fuel cell project explains
that fuel cells are interesting because
they generate electricity from hydrogen
and air the technology has been in
development for more than 20 years but
now it's finally become a practical
option to use as a vehicle's main drive
system not least because of the progress
made in essential peripheral systems
like the high-voltage batteries and
electric motors from BMW z drive
development that all adds up to
promising means of powering vehicles
some package planets join into Santa for
take on teddy bear cave now filling up
with hydrogen can be a fast and
straightforward process just take the
cap off connect the fueling nozzle and
start filling the tank that takes about
the same time as filling up with
gasoline or diesel
the coalfield closed 10 points out that
customers will only buy the cars if they
know they can fill up with hydrogen BMW
has launched a program for Germany in
conjunction with government and industry
that foresees the construction of 50
filling stations at present 19 are in
service and bone off seems confident
that all 50 will be completed by late
2016 but that's just a first step a
crucial factor in making hydrogen more
widely accepted is cooperation with
industry to expand the hydrogen station
network throughout Germany tough a
mitzvah production but also phone number
to direct water injection into the
combustion chamber used so far only in
Motorsports this technology also has
great potential and drive systems for
road vehicles awesome of them Oliver's
then amela explains that all the water
is normally used to put out fires this
is an internal combustion engine that
puts fire and water together water is
actually used to enhance the performance
of this m4 engine after passing through
the charge air cooler the intake system
injects it into the intake air where it
cools the chamber the water's atomized
so it will turn into vapor before
entering the intake manifold plenum
chamber the high concentration of the
cool gas boosts the performance this
principle has been implemented in the
water injection system of this safety
car he's a motor oil mikasa expert
system pets technisch younger sister BMW
is integrating the technology in the
three-cylinder engine of this volume
produced one series here the water isn't
just put through the intake system but
directly injected into the combustion
chamber that cools the engine and adds
up to lower fuel consumption especially
at full throttle isis team Bowen van
amela points out that a system can be
built with a water tank that the
customer can fill up regularly with
distilled water but he sees that as
quite inconvenient BMW is working on a
way to of recovering the water produced
by condensation in the air conditioning
which can be collected in a container
chemically this water
ideal for feeding into a water injection
system h Blitzen on Jesus Vasa grid have
ended home diva CH Blitzen surprising
number three the BMW 2 Series active
tourer plug-in hybrid will soon be
rounding out the e drive range on clock
Laguna elaborates that BMW took the
unchanged front part of a 218 I and
installed a 1.2 liter three-cylinder BMW
twinpower turbo engine with 100
kilowatts of power and 220 newton meters
of torque then they added an electric
drive module over the rear axle to bring
it up to the performance level of a 225
I in effect that gives the car all-wheel
drive at no extra cost so with this
alternative the buyers getting real
added value it is Mon be able to India
restore nation vol BMW is taking a
multi-pronged approach that includes
efficient gasoline and diesel powered
engines plug-in hybrids and soon
hydrogen fuel cell drives to take a bite
out of co2 emissions